-Melissa and Rachel,
your team is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Beeping ]
♪♪
"Ironic," Alanis Morisette!
Now, hmm...
Who is going to sing this one?
You have to get all
the lyrics correct.
I think I'll sing it.
-Yeah? Alright. Go for it.
Here we go. Let's get ready!
Whenever you're ready,
we'll start the track.
[ Applause ]
[ "Ironic" by Alanis Morisette
playing ]
-She's gonna get it.
She's going to get it.
-♪ And isn't it ironic,
don't you think? ♪
♪ It's like rain
on your wedding day ♪
♪ It's a free ride
when you've already paid ♪
♪ It's the good advice
that you just didn't take ♪
♪ And who would have thought?
It figures ♪
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was so violent.
That was so...[ Laughs ]
[ Laughing ]
It was so aggressive.
-Oh, my God.
It was...I feel violated.
[ Laughing ]
-I'm so sorry.
50,000 points for your team.
Ana, let's see it
in slow motion.
Let's see what happens
[ Crowd groans, laughs ]
-[ Laughing ]
-What is going on? [ Laughs ]
-Why always on Ana?
-Oh, my gosh. Unbelievable.
I'm so sorry.
Fred, Ana, it is your turn.
Let's see what song
you guys get.
-We're gonna get wet.
You gotta accept it.
[ Beeping ]
-"Love Shack" by the B-52s!
Who's gonna sing this one?
Well, it's a Fred who sings it,
so...
-It is a Fred who does
sing the lead.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-I can be -- I'll be --
I'm very damp.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, I'll give it a shot.
-Here comes the music.
Fred, whenever you're ready.
[ "Love Shack" by
the B-52s playing ]
-♪ If you see a faded sign ♪
♪ At the side of the road
that says ♪
-Yes!
-♪ Fifteen miles ♪
♪ To the Looove Shack! ♪
♪ Love Shack, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I'm headin' down
the Atlanta highway ♪
-You nervous? You nervous?
-♪ Lookin' for
-♪ The love getaway ♪
-♪ Headed for the love getaway ♪
♪ I got me a car,
it's as big as a whale ♪
♪ And we're headin' on down
to the Love Shack ♪
-Woo!
-♪ I got me a Chrysler,
it seats about twenty ♪
-Get ready!
-♪ So hurry up and bring
your jukebox money ♪
-Ohh!
-Ahh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Dratch!
Dratch, you are the best.
Yeah, you nailed it right there!
You nailed it!
-That was good!
-That is 50,000 points
for your team.
Let's see what happened
to you guys in slow motion.
Watch Dratch with the block.
She just puts her hand up.
She knew he was gonna
nail that one.
-Ahh!
-Well done, right there.
Okay.
Guys, it is time
for the final round.
-Oh, boy.
-And for Season 2,
we made things bigger
and wetter than ever before
Watch your heads because we've
got new boom mics coming in.
-Oh, no.
-Happy holidays.
It's about to
be a wet Christmas.
Ho, ho, ho.
-What's this? What?
-Okay.
-Uh-oh.
-All four of you are going
to take turns singing
so pay attention to your screen.
You're gonna switch off
line by line.
When the music stops,
you have to nail
the lyrics or you and your
partner will get drenched.
And this round is worth,
ready for this?
200,000 points.
-What?!
-Whoever wins this wins
the whole thing.
Let's say what
our final song is.
-Uh-oh. I'm scared
I'm gonna lose it for us.
[ Beeping ]
-Do you know this song?
-"Last Christmas" by Wham!
-A little, a little,
a little.
-Rachel,
you are gonna start us off.
Here we go.
[ "Last Christmas"
by Wham! plays ]
♪ Last Christmas,
I gave you my heart ♪
-Ana.
♪ Day, you gave it away ♪
-Melissa, you're up.
-♪ This year,
to save me from tears ♪
-Fred, you're up next.
-♪ I'll give it
to someone special ♪
-Rachel.
-♪ Once bitten and twice shy ♪
-Ana.
-♪ I keep my distance,
but you still catch my eye ♪
-Melissa.
-♪ Tell me, baby,
do you recognize me? ♪
-Fred.
-♪ Well, it's been a year... ♪
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Laughs ]
No, it doesn't surprise me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have a winner.
Melissa and Rachel
are tonight's
"That's My "Jam champions!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Melissa, here.
You are the champs!
Whoo!
-Sir.
-Your glasses are --
-You glasses are -- Sir.
Oh, my God. Ana Gasteyer.
Fred Armisen.